the end of the federal era is a huge
blow to tennis and his millions of fans
worldwide but in true fedra-esque style
he's found the perfect way to bow out
reuniting the big four against the rest
of the world on the same side of the net
as his greatest rival and friend Rafa
Nadal and in London the city of many of
his iconic moments I just felt it would
be wonderful having Borg on the chair
having the greatest players on the
planet right now alongside me and I just
felt it wouldn't feel lonely you know
because often when you retire you're
alone in the court you just probably
lost your last match and you're all
emotional talking how much it meant to
you being in the game and I thought I
didn't want that I didn't want that sad
moment I wanted to be happy and more
like a party party mode I was able to to
to have an amazing to create an amazing
rivalry together
and in the hand something that probably
we are very proud I have been a friendly
driver you know it's 20 grand
including the eight Wimbledon titles
have all been achieved with the style of
a ballet dancer his movement and
effortless power inspiring many players
but replicated by none of them
relatively untroubled by injury for a
quarter of a century the injured knee
that's kept him out of tennis since
Wimbledon 2021 has finally said enough
is enough I think it should be good
enough for a doubles to be honest but
for the singles uh honestly I haven't
trained at all the last three months and
it would just be too much to ask for for
the the body and I am not willing to put
all the risk on the line for that Roger
Federer and his agent Tony godzick came
with the Laver cup to honor his Idol Rod
Laver and in a way to mimic the Ryder
Cup he long ago eclipsed his hero in
terms of titles and when he finally says
goodbye to tennis it is going to be a
special moment in sporting history
Federer has given so much to the sport
it's the end of an era and there will be
tears on and off the court
Jackie Bell trout Sky News